the body of the latest victim of alleged
police brutality in chile
lies in wake in a low-income
neighborhood of santiago
twenty-seven-year-old francisco martinez
romero was a juggler
a street artist who traveled around
south america but who met his end
in a small lakeside town in his home
country
since he was a child he loved using his
hands juggling
he was an artist who never hurt anyone
and who used harmless tin swords for his
act
martinez was shot dead after he charged
a policeman
who had first fired two warning shots at
him during an argument over a routine
identity check
it's unleashed a new wave of outrage and
vandalism
from southern chile to the capital
while his body lay in wake street
artists paid homage to martinez
the delegation of indigenous mapuches
received special
applause to kill francisco in broad
daylight in front of a crowd of people
is
not an isolated incident it's part of
the police's modus operandi
in what appears to be a coincidence
martinez's family says the victim was
the uncle of a 16 year old protester
who was nearly killed last october when
a policeman threw him over a bridge
into an almost dry river
as then the government has asked police
for an exhaustive
and quick investigation into the
incident
people have been arriving all day from
all over the capitol not just to express
their condolences to the family but also
their determination to continue
demonstrating
until there is justice but given that
the policeman who fired the five shots
is insisting it was
in self-defense there's no guarantee at
this stage
that there will be the verdict that all
the people here are demanding
human rights monitors say only a
fraction of the hundreds of officers
accused of abuses
have been tried and sentenced and guilty
or not
this killing has only added more fuel to
the ongoing social unrest
in chile often flamed by allegations of
police brutality
lucia newman al jazeera santiago